how's it going resumes today we're gonna
do some more sculpturing for your
breasts first off we have Shrek let's
make some magic baby okay great
starting off let's make the neck about
five million times bigger all right that
looks great
Oh God something is happening over there
I don't know what try to make it gun
here and this [ __ ] thing just drops
into a volcano
alright let's make his nose it looks
like a Diglett nice all right now yeah
we're getting somewhere
we're getting some good results lights
through the ears how do I do the ears
great right oh it's making nostril work
solid shade well it works moderately now
we need to make his math I guess his
mouth could be his chin not I think
about it all right let's smoothen shrink
out a little bit he looks a little tense
oh god it works holy [ __ ] yeah
there we go fantastic all right I think
we're done it's time it's time to paint
him bad oh man man Nana Nana Nana Nana
Nana so I should watch the Shrek baby
boo what's the trick I don't know now
maybe I'm a Shrek Shrek ooh that looks
good let's define the nostrils a little
bit more because I can't [ __ ] see
Oh God no Shrek you're not Hitler it's
pretty accurate I'm pretty I'm pretty
happy with it I think it it really
reflects his character and I think we'll
save this one next up Justin Biber
all right this is a good picture cuz we
actually get some definition of that
face let's see here
looks good make that nose a little tiny
area yeah that looks good
make the ears pop a little bit more
Justin you're gonna look so good Justin
let's make those luscious lip pop oh god
no sure you know what why not oh I can
import what oh my god we have to try
this so how does this work
oh my god this is amazing
Oh Oh the chin oh my god beeps you look
shocked
holy [ __ ] no but it just looks like him
me it is him how the future of
Technology man I don't even
now you can 3d print this and have your
own little Justin Bieber doll and do
whatever you want with makeup blow-up I
don't care that is fabulous
look at this lips Justin where you win a
fight again Justin Justin what are you
doing Justin I told you you're not an
elephant you must learn to listen to me
don't Justin don't eat your face that is
rude what I'm paying girls please buy my
new album it's really good it's that's
amazing
I'll have to do myself now because
otherwise I'm a hypocrite let's take the
the best picture that there is of me all
right let's make art brush let's watch
the results it only kind of works if
you're at this angle actually doesn't
work oh my god what have I done
it looks so creepy that was maybe not
the greatest idea
all right so jacksepticeye suggested Kim
Kardashian's butt so who do we start
with all right I guess we start with
this
there we go white boring flat but let's
boobalicious that little thing I mean
but delicious that does not look better
at all I don't know what I was thinking
my god this is Miley Cyrus come on how
do I make a bigger baby girl oh there's
a nice booty oh yeah that's a nice
birthday daddy's very nice that if we
would leave that you got a tiara oh yeah
yeah that's a nice booty had me like mmm
all right we have the ass crack there we
go
that about does it that is probably my
favorite ass crack of old fat ass cracks
let's paint that bikini thong has to be
there and she has she's been sitting on
the sand there we go
I'd say this is probably like 100
percent accurate or something like that
maybe 102 percent but yeah looks really
good on a man that is that is some hot
[ __ ] man let's save that one because you
never know when 20 you never know when
you might beat me all right press that's
all the time about the sculpture today
it's always a lot of fun
leave a comment who you want to see me
sculpture or what in the next episode
thank you for liking this video and
never here's a breakfast for you
[Music]